la politique d'austérité économique
semble désormais bien loin en allemagne
avec l'annoncé d'un nouveau plan de 130
milliards d'euros la chancelière angela
merkel continue de soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat et les entreprises une large
panoplie de mesures qui consisteront
notamment d'une baisse temporaire de la
tva jusqu'à la fin de l'année à des
transferts de dettes des municipalités
vers l'état fédéral ou encore en une
baisse du prix de l'électricité pour lés
particuliers
nous sommes confrontés à la plus grave
crise de développement économique de
l'histoire de l'allemagne mais cela se
voit aujourd'hui avec les 7 millions de
travailleurs au chômage partiel
ils en sont la preuve
et il est clair que tout cela nécessite
une réponse courageuse dans le but de
garantir des emplois des maintenir et de
relancer l'économie
même si l'allemagne a moins souffert de
la pandémie que ses voisins européens le
taux de chômage vient de dépasser les 6%
dans le pays dès mars le gouvernement
avait pris les devants avec un plan
gigantesque de 1000 milliards d'euros
prévoyant des aides aux entreprises et
des milliards d'euros de prêts garantis
la riposte allemand de s'ajoute aux
multiples stratégies mises en place dans
toute l'ue a eu une réponse coordonnée
par la banque centrale européenne la bce
a déjà annoncé un programme d'urgence
doté de 750 milliards d'euros pour
racheter des obligations publiques et
privées ce dernier devrait d'ailleurs
être renforcées de plusieurs centaines
de milliards d'euros d'aidés européennes
cruciales pour relancer l'économie des
pays les plus durement touchés comme
l'italie le président du conseil s'est
félicité de la solidarité européenne
face à la crise on mérite c'est le cas
de le dire de retrouver le sourire la
joie au bout de semaine de durs
sacrifices c'est bien de rappeler que si
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans ces
conditions nous sommes parmi les
premiers pays européens qui peuvent se
permettre de relancer les différents
activités économiques et sociales en
toute sécurité c'est parce que nous
avons accepté tous ensemble de faire des
sacrifices
la riposte des états membres et de la
bce ne permettra pas d'éviter à
l'économie européenne d'afficher de très
mauvais chiffres
la présidente de la banque centrale
européenne christine lagarde a déjà
annoncé un recul du pib de la zone euro
compris entre 8 et 12% cette année